el hobbit sigue rondando tokio 2020 dos
atletas han dado positivo por kobe 19
dos atletas de salto con pértiga uno de
ellos es el estadounidense sam que
andrés uno de los favoritos y doble
campeona del mundo el otro es el
argentino germán chiaraviglio él anunció
su positivo a través de las redes
sociales ambos deportistas se encuentran
bien de salud aislados en un hotel pero
quedan por fuera de estos juegos
olímpicos con estos casos ya suman 20 en
total los atletas que han dado positivo
desde el primero de julio una medalla
amarga una medalla de plata en el judo
en la categoría de -70 y ocho kilos para
francia para la francesa marlena malonga
quien perdió su combate en tan sólo un
minuto y diez segundos ante la japonesa
saori amada quien se quedó muy contento
con su resultado fue la brasileña mayra
aguiar quien consiguió uno de los dos
bronces en esta misma categoría y bueno
francia que espera una nueva medalla ya
que las francesas se clasificaron en la
final de esgrima florete por equipos
finales que disfrutarán después de haber
venció en semifinal en un tremendo
encuentro al as
la final será ante el equipo del comité
olímpico ruso